Visit St. Petersburg's largest and most famous museum, the Hermitage.
Here, you will witness the majestic splendor...
...of former imperial palaces' ceremonial halls and feel the grandeur of its atmosphere...
...while taking a journey through time...
...from the era of Peter III and Catherine the Great...
...to that of Alexander I and Nicholas II.
This magnificent cultural and historical art museum...
...contains unique exhibits from around the world.
Surprises and curiosities await...
...from the subtleties of the still-working, jewel-encrusted peacock golden clock...
...to the rich collection of world-renowned paintings,...
...sculptures, murals and tapestries.
What could be more memorable than to experience for yourself...
...thousands of world-famous masterpieces...
...spanning eras and genres from Baroque to Minimalist...
...while exploring the former heart of Russia's imperial past?
A tour through the Hermitage will create memories to last a lifetime.